en el reino unido se ha identificado una
nueva cepa de coronavirus que se está
propagando a toda velocidad
boris johnson había prometido que la
navidad no se cancelaría pero tuvo que
cambiar de opinión
no podemos continuar con la navidad como
estaba planeado en inglaterra y quienes
viven en áreas de nivel 4 no deben
mezclarse con nadie fuera de su propio
hogar en navidad de rangel show esto
efectivamente restringe las reuniones
familiares para millones de británicos
que viven en londres y en el sureste
inglaterra también en el continente hay
nuevas medidas estrictas en este
restaurante en berna suiza es el último
servicio de cena en un mes las
autoridades han ordenado que los
restaurantes y gimnasios cierren durante
30 días en italia las tiendas no
esenciales cerrarán y se les pedirá a
las personas que se queden en casa
estamos imponiendo una zona roja en todo
el territorio nacional entre el 21 de
diciembre y el 6 de enero estará
prohibido viajar entre regiones al
cesionario en españa aumenta la
preocupación por una posible
o la de infecciones en madrid solo
pueden reunirse grupos de seis personas
en comparación con las días permitidas
inicialmente no poder estar con todos
nuestros seres queridos en estos días
tan especiales pero hay que pensar que
es mucho más importante evitar los
contagios evitar la enfermedad evitar al
fin y al cabo el cob y 19 los cierres de
navidad también están en vigor en
austria y república checa